you need to let the police handle this I
tried
I'm not giving up on my mom
this is FaceTime oh gosh I need you to
write a couple of things down the car
keys I just said write it down you're
not writing it down
Kevin and I are headed to LAX and we
need you to pick us up on Monday keep
your location on the entire time I'm
away no fun got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is Grace Allen please leave a
message
Mom where are you guys
my mom never came home from her trip I
don't know where she is I'm calling
about a guest you had
um does anyone speak English I'm sorry
this is Elijah Park please I need your
help the FBI doesn't have jurisdiction
to investigate in Colombia so is there
anything I can do the best thing you can
do to help us is just wait by your phone
I'm not giving up on my mom
this hotel and ask for their security
footage
says she sees two American tourists
what did he buy just this you think he
did something to her
you're going through Kevin's email you
need to let the police handle this I
tried but we're running out of time who
are these people this woman calls him
Darren
you weren't gonna tell me my mom was
dating a felon you need to trust me on
this shocking new footage has leaked
online
I have some questions regarding
something we're looking into has your
mom ever gone by any other names
what the strangest case I've ever seen
there may be more than meets the eyes
there are some legit questions
oh my God